and thank you very much for giving us
your time this morning could you just
tell us why you moved to Devon how long
we've been here that sort of thing
yeah we moved here about it's almost
three years ago and we move down from
New York to be closer to my son
he lives in Cornwall but not too close
to him so giving me the own space
so we thought we'd moved to this area
because we've been to Dartington and top
Nathan and we thought nice to be on the
edge of Dartmoor and near the nice
coastline as well brilliant thank you
and can you tell us what you found when
you moved here and what your experience
of living here was like and when we
first moved we were a little bit
apprehensive because we felt sort of
walking around that um the estate here
was look a bit rough and but we thought
well we'll move here and we'll see how
it goes and if we really don't settle
here then we'll try and find somewhere
else okay
and obviously soon after you moved in
you had your first couple of experiences
meeting the vines and hearing the noise
level in the area can you explain what
life was like living around with the
Bryan's living in gypsy Lane we noticed
things were difficult right you know
within a few days of moving here and we
started hearing shouting and a lot of
noise and cars being driven up and down
the road very fast and and shout yes
just banging and shouting and that
happened very soon and we wondered you
know why this was all going on and and
the more it went on the worse it seemed
to get and made us feel quite edgy and
nervous of being here to the point that
after a few months we decided that we
really wouldn't use the front entrance
to come into the in and out of the house
when we were fortunate that we had a
rear entrance that goes into a communal
carpark so it gave us another way in and
out and we didn't have to be involved in
any confrontations which would witnessed
three okay and obviously started
speaking to neighbors I think that's
quite a good community around the area
and what was the general impression of
living in gypsy Lane well we we
discovered that actually the problems
have been going on for quite some time
and we because we were new it took us
quite a while to sort of suss out what
was going on and who was involved and
and neighbors did say you know you want
to be a little bit careful about this
certain family and they've been here for
a long time caused a lot of problems and
people are quite nervous about them
quite apprehensive and don't really want
they sort of shut themselves away and
don't want to do anything about it and
basically I was told by one neighbor
just keep your eyes down don't say hello
and just get on with your life which I
found quite difficult because it
impacted your life so much no you know
you could hear the noise and the fights
in in your own room in your own front
room and and in the bedrooms as well so
there was not much escape from it
okay thank you and obviously the
anti-social behaviour orders are now in
place and none of the Brian's with the
anti-social behaviour orders are now
living in this area and you are banned
from what firstly so house what's life
right now totally different I mean I can
now go out in the front garden my
daughter can walk out if we can all use
the front entrance to and the house
which is really good people the children
are allowed to ride the bikes up and
down which parents want to let them do
that before neighbors can talk to each
other people are doing their gardens at
the front now which is actually only you
know the roadside where a lot of the
problems happened and and it's a much
nicer feel I think it's going to take
quite a while to for the community to
really get over at all but I think it's
looking positive definitely good and
lastly obviously it's quite a daunting
prospect of being a courtroom to be a
witness
in any case was it worth it absolutely
yeah I mean I was really nervous about
the process and but we had such great
support when we were actually in the
court and I'm waiting to go in the court
I mean I was nervous definitely but yeah
I would in fact I will try if anything
if I was ever in this situation I've
been you know I wouldn't believe it as
probably as long as I did to actually
make statements and go to court needs
dealing with much faster than probably
this community need to deal with these
problems John just to clarify and you
mentioned that it's at the community a
long time to address the problems here
could you just explain what you meant
and how you think in future we could
speed that up mm-hmm
well the difficulty was that people when
things were actually happening people
some people would phone for the police
to come and try and sort something out
and when the police got here sometimes
it might be too late for the police to
do anything because they whatever was
going on and calm down
but the difficulty of the police hand
was actually people didn't want to come
forward and make statements and without
statements that the police couldn't take
any action without actually them saying
anything obviously they could if they
saw something but most the time they
didn't so you know it did take longer
for the for the whole thing to be sorted
out just because people were scared or
apprehensive to actually make statements
to the police and and you know I wish
everyone I don't even match sooner and
the reason why I did it in the end
was because I thought someone was going
to get seriously hurt